A safe water infrastructure is a
necessity for a healthy community.
It provides clean water to your taps,
it removes waste water and it protects the
community from flooding by managing stormwater.
The government is currently reviewing how
these three water services are delivered
across the country and along with other councils
we've committed to that first phase of reform.
In return we've received eight million of
stimulus funding which is already helping
improve our water infrastructure.
In the second stage of reform the government is
proposing that water services will be delivered
by new regional or multi-regional entities
and billed to households separately
rather than by the Council.
It's not clear yet whether signing up to
this stage of the reforms is actually going
to benefit Waimakariri's ratepayers and
that's because our water infrastructure is
well maintained, it's compliant and
high quality compared with other areas.
Until we hear from the government later this year
we won't know exactly how this will impact
on us but we will keep you up to date.
Visit waimakariri.govt.nz/letstalk
to find out more.